ما عل
الدن الله يرضى عليه في الدنيا كله الله
يرضى عليه في الدنيا وفي الاخره والله
راضي والله راضي والله مرضي والله مرضي
هذا اهمي يكون مض ضين عليه والله مرضى
ابوه وامه كل ما يزعل روح لهم ايش بكم
يابا ايش بقول بروح الرامله مزعل من
اصحابه بزعل ابو وامه حبايبي ياما حبيبي
ياما الله يرحمك ياما يا سامر يخربك عليك
يما ويجمعك مع صد والشهدا يا رب يطلق
لسانك على سالك يجعل مواك الجنه يا سامر
ياما ويجمعك مع الصدقين والشهداء ياما يا
رب حبيبي ياما راس قلبي ياما يا سم حبيبي
يا الله يرحم روحك يا الله يرحمك ياما يا
سامر الله يخفف ترابك عليك ياما ويجمعك مع
الصديقين والشهداء يا الله يرضى عنك في
الدنيا وفي الاخره امين الله يرضى عنك
ياما في الدنيا وفي الاخره الله يما يرضى
عنك في الدنيا وفي الاخره الله يما يسامحك
ويغفر
وخفف ترابك عليكما لسانك عن سالك يجعل
مواك الجنه يا يجعل م في الجنه يا الله
يسامحك في الدنيا
ولا الله يا رب صبرنا عراك الله
صنا والله ريحته مسك والله ريحته مسك
ريحته كل الدم اللي فيهما
كل
ه